TEAM IS SOANDERSSON.
FREDERIK ANDERSEN.
GETS THE PASS FROM FOX.
RANGERS HAVE WON THREE IN A ROW
HONESTY, SOFT-SPOKEN S!
SHARP ANGL EXAMPLE.
>> Sam: B KAKKO,
INTERCEPTED.
BROUGHT BACK IN. FRANK VATRANO.
BRADEN SCHNEIDER IS THERE.
JUSTIN BRAUN.
THAT PASS OUT IN FRONT.
COMBINATION OF VATRANO AND
LINDGREN. FORWARDSSFFERENT MATC
THERE AND WAITED FOR THE PASS TO
COME TO HIM.
RANGERS SCOREDPLAY IS OVER.
THIS PASS TIPPED ACROSS AND ANDT
THING WAS ABOUT THAT PLAY BY PA
TO FOX, FOX DOES WHAT HE DOES
BACKHANDS IT DEEP.
POWER PLAY IS OVER.KOV JUST THR
IT FROM BEHIND THE NET GOING TOY
SHIFTS, YOU GOT TO EARN YOUR  I!
HE SCORES! TO GET THE
BACK TO SKJEI, SHOT BLOCKED. IT
CAROLINA WITH TWO GOALS HERE IN
JOE. HIRD A
>> Joe: WOW, HE HAS TO WAIT
UNTIL HIS TEAMMATE COMES OUT OF
THE ZONE, MAKES THAT SAVE, THIS
OFF THE POST AND BACK OUT AND
THEN STROMNG, SHOOTING --ATCH I
>> Joe: YEAH, THE RANGERS
TERAVAINEN BANKS IT  SECONDS RE.
>> Joe: